we're gonna begin with this an exclusive
interview with Mike Bloomberg who's
adding his name to the list of Democrats
who say president Trump should be
impeached we spoke to mr. Bloomberg in
Aurora Colorado yesterday it's his first
television interview since jumping into
the presidential race last month the
former Republican mayor of New York City
was in Colorado to talk about one of his
signature issues gun violence he's very
passionate about this
we asked him why he chose to enter the
campaign so late I want to talk about
you getting in the race because when you
were on CBS this morning in September
are you sitting here going I wish I had
done it no I never think back there was
not a road for me when Joe was in the
race to get through because we would
have split the votes what happened
between September and now I looked at
our national government getting worse
the way we are behaving overseas and
domestically led by our president
I said back in 2016 he is the wrong
person for the job he doesn't have the
temperament or the ethics the intellect
to do the job and I watched and I said
we just can't have another four years of
this and then I watched all the
candidates and I just thought to myself
Donald Trump would eat him up
you think all the candidates who are
running today he would eat them up
let me rephrase it I think that I would
do the best job of competing with him
and beating him one of the other things
you said in September was that Joe Biden
is a friend did you talk to Joe Biden
ahead of time to say I'm getting in no I
did not you still consider him a friend
yeah sure why would he not be I don't
know I'm thinking with friends like you
who needs enemies you are friendly with
other great TV presenters morning yes
and you're all competing for the same
get but I'm not trying to take your job
well I'm not trying to take his job
either he doesn't have the job of
fresney United States and neither do I
at the moment the person that has it is
Donald Trump I'm trying to take away the
job from Donald Trump
nobody's saying Mayor Bloomberg met they
either say oh thank god he's getting in
thank God now I know I'm going to vote
for or I hear what the hell
he thinking is this a big ego stroke
well how do you respond to both of those
the second one I have the same rights as
anybody else it does it take an ego yeah
I guess it takes an ego to think that
you could do the job I have 12 years of
experience in City Hall and I think if
you go back today and ask most people
about those 12 years they would say that
that not me but the team that I put
together made an enormous difference in
New York City and New York City
benefited from it and continues to
benefit from it today from what we did
then stop and frisk you recently
apologized for that
some people are suspicious of the timing
of your apology well the mark of a
intelligent competent person is when
they make a mistake they have the guts
to stand up and say I made a mistake I'm
sorry we don't question your belief that
you made a mistake I think the question
is the timing that you realize you made
them well nobody asked me about it until
I started running for president so come
on are you saying to people that you
realize you had made a mistake before
but you just didn't mention it until now
I think we were overzealous at the time
to do it our intent was to do anything
we could to stop the carnage the murder
rate and what was surprising is when we
stopped doing it a little bit we thought
crime would go up it didn't it went down
you know it should have would have been
could have I can't help that but I in
looking back made a mistake I'm sorry I
apologized
let's go fight the NRA and find other
ways to stop the murders and
incarceration those are things that I'm
committed to do and the more I do that
the better off everybody is the next
debate is December and Cory Booker said
that it could possibly be on that debate
stage no one of color there would be
more billionaires than the race than
black people is that a problem to you
Cory Booker endorsed me a number of
times and I endorsed Cory Booker number
times he's very well-spoken he's got
some good ideas it would be better the
more diverse any group is but the public
is out there picking and choosing and
rowing down this field the truth of the
matter is you had a lot of diversity in
the candidates some of whom were very
competent why they aren't there as you
narrowed it down you have to talk to
other people who are experts I don't
know part of the conversation is here we
go another old white gentleman isn't it
time for change isn't it time for
somebody maybe but lots of people can
enter there was no reason if you wanted
to enter and run for president nine
states you could have done that but
don't complain to me that you're not in
the race it was up to you and I thought
there was a lot of diversity in the
group of democratic aspirants entry is
not a barrier so you're saying if you
want diversity then get in that is
exactly a good place to phrase it thank
you very much Mayor Bloomberg was really
he had a lot to say about a lot of
different issues but he clearly is up
for the fight he knows it's going to be
a fight he knows it's not going to be
easy and he really said I've been doing
a lot of thinking because I really
hadn't intended to run but he's so
distressed and so disturbed by what he
sees happening in Washington that he
does think he can make a difference
polling at 5% in one poll which is
considering how ladies enter to the
races is a is a strong number but and
then he told me he plans to go to every
single state before the election because
I said you know how are people going to
get to know you he goes well I'm talking
to you right now I'll be doing
interviews we have campaign ads but he
intends to go to every single state
before ya know we'll see noteworthy to
hear him say that he hadn't been asked
about stopping frisk before you asked
him because if you look at the record
back in January he was asked at the
Naval Academy and he did not apologize
them and in terms of saying it was an
overzealous policy well a federal judge
said it was a policy of indirect racial
profiling so it'll be interesting to see
how when people hear that if it if it is
an apology that resonates I think he
regrets saying that I think people were
jumping on the timing of it but he says
look I made a mistake but I can do
better I want to do better and let's
move on it's clear about that